I'm Jordan I'm a sophomore at Harvard
I'm first-generation college student my
dad works two three jobs my dad my mom's
still working my grandparents you know
coming from Puerto Rico and that kind of
thing and really not go not having any
education so from one from two
generations ago my grandparents not even
going to middle school to me being at
Harvard I think that is not only
symbolic of the hard work that it took
to get here but it just shows that you
know you work hard you can really do
anything when my dad always telling me
you know education is what's gonna take
you to the next level no matter where
you go to school no matter if you're in
high school no matter if you're at the
best university in the world Khan
Academy can be used anywhere just having
that 24-hour you know free online
resource that I have used in the past
and I'm going to continue using to
eventually help my help me reach my
goals of one day going to medical school
and one day eventually becoming a doctor
being the first doctor in my family is
gonna be something that's you know
remarkable and it's gonna be middle out
to my family
[Music]